the summer is here the time of year when
so many people's thoughts turn to taking
a holiday
except this year will be very different
across some of our
favorite european destinations the rules
are tightening
portugal the latest country to impose a
quarantine on the british visitors who
are allowed in
that's now the default position for most
european nations
the situation that applies to the united
kingdom at present is that um travelers
who are vaccinated
who are fully vaccinated uh or who have
an essential reason
to come to the eu should be allowed by
member states uh
to um to arrive into the eu and um
i can i can also add that from the
commission side
we of course expect member states to
apply this recommendation fully there is
a clear message from germany and france
that they expect european countries to
put health concerns above
tourist revenue and to either deny entry
to visitors from the uk
or to impose a lengthy quarantine for
those whose businesses
depend on british tourists this is a
bleak time
the algarve should be alive with people
instead it's quiet
the algarve was british tourism
it is british tourism without british
tourism without those numbers
then it becomes very difficult to keep
hotels open
um it becomes very difficult to keep
restaurants open bars open
and when they can't stay open then
obviously the area closes
and then even the smaller percentages of
people like the spanish the italians the
french
dutch that also come to the algarve but
in much smaller numbers
even them combined uh it's not enough to
replace the brits
but in brussels they insist it's too
early to make concessions
european diplomats i've spoken to say
they are very wary about the rising
number
of delta variant cases in the uk and
they point out that just about
anyone arriving in britain has to
quarantine even if they're
fully vaccinated why they ask should it
be any different
for people making the reverse journey
from britain
into the european union so should both
sides be
cutting a bit more slack particularly
for those who are fully vaccinated
people who in theory
present a very low risk one of the
the things we're trying to do worldwide
is increase people's
willingness to accept the vaccine and
part of that is showing people what the
world is like when you're fully
vaccinated
because if people don't see the vaccine
as a path to get their life back to
pursue the values that are important to
them like traveling like going on
vacation
they're not going to get vaccinated
tourism is a touchstone to normality
that's why we pine for it
but for the moment it remains out of
reach a
hope rather than a reality
adam parsons sky news brussels